professor Ron in recent years there's
been these horrific stories about you
know captives people that have been
stowed away in someone's home for years
from a screenwriting aspect what would
you have this writer do if well some
type of law enforcement is approaching a
situation like that they've discovered
maybe a tip from a neighbor and it turns
out there's been few people living in
the basement something to that nature
something really horrific yeah from I my
colleagues in law enforcement that I
understand is first off back up do not
go in by yourself to not go in with just
you and your partner make sure you have
not necessarily SWAT but depending on
how you know how hostile person is you
want to approach the door with not
trepidation but you want to be careful
you don't want to tip them off you maybe
pretend that you're the dye t diaper man
well that's the only one but but you
want to you've got to get them to the
door is what I'm trying to get at you
have to get them to answer the door
because these are recluse people recluse
and reckless it's not something that you
want leiser are on the line here so you
have to be very cautious and you have to
be very meticulous in your thinking try
to always know the answers before you
even ask a question type of thing where
you will anticipate okay scenarios
that's what cops are do you you'll know
if it's this scenario will do this if
it's this scenario will do that if it's
this with it I mean you'll have as much
recon as you can about you know anybody
know how where are the rooms in the
house where the escape routes stuff like
that you have people in the backyard you
have people in the front yard typical
cop stuff that you see I'm literally
cops that's show all the time but you
want to do it carefully so that you
don't
impede on or the possibility or create
the possibility of escalated violence in
some of these cases it seems like there
was a woman harboring a husband
boyfriend who it seemed like everything
was fine from the outside and then you
find out that this person was an
accomplice by allowing that person to
get away with it so if there was let's
say the the sweet doting wife at the
door how would you have the officer
approached that I've heard a lot of
cases like this yeah shocked to find out
that generally from my understanding oh
and this is maybe more from the news
than from the phone conversations is you
give them tells you kind of hint hint at
things and let them respond with their
eyes or your reading their body language
to let to know because generally with a
female it's not the female that is the
perpetrator it is the the male unit but
there's still an accomplice because
they've been well are they are they an
accomplice or are they a victim as well
that's the biggest thing that I would
interject particular as a right I would
think that they would most likely be a
victim that's been beaten down trodden
as well and not that they're going to
show scars on their face they they may
have burn marks on their arms but you
know don't touch the face as they say I
mean it's easier if you find a beaten-up
woman to go so go okay domestic violence
let me and now I'm a cop if it's
something that's a little more covert a
little more I don't say cold but hidden
you have you have to you have to yet as
with anything you have to you have to
tread lightly and and and and ask
probing questions that might get them
out maybe say can you step out on the
you know
on the porch please you know I like or I
like the idea as a writer of you know
maybe a traveling book salesman if they
even have them anymore do they have them
anymore i don't know but somebody
something that you know you can you come
out and see this arm now actually i'm
going to twist this i believe it was Ted
Bundy would use a little dog and say can
you help me find my little dog maybe you
can use the the same philosophy of can
you come out and help me you know do
something maybe it's fine my little dog
but this is law enforcement speaking so
that we you understand what's going on
and then be able to question them away
from the person because as soon as she
steps away you're going to draw out the
person is going to go what the f what's
going on why are you here what are you
doing and then you can cut them if
you're going to be that bold writers
choice
you